que se conoce desde el estado de la
planta nuclear de saporilla y cuáles
podrían ser las consecuencias si hay un
daño estructural es exagerado hablar de
un segundo chernóbil
Hola qué tal Buenos días de María Clara
Bueno no es exagerado hablar de un
posible externo si se daña la planta
estamos hablando de la planta más grande
de Europa por lo tanto puede haber un
riesgo digamos
unas nubes nuclear es un riesgo
peligroso que no no puede afectar solo a
ucranias sino a todos lo que dijo Rafael
gross es muy importante porque en
realidad lo que está diciendo las partes
se acusan mutuamente quienes está
disparando pero lo que es real es está
viendo
estos bombardeos muy cerca de la planta
lo cual
creo sí dice esto las palabras es como
cuarto Este es el peligro real que
existen hubo incendios no lo forma la
agencia nacional que monitorea esto
distancia muy altamente que no ha habido
daños está de material radiactivo que
sería
para Cuáles son los peligros de de puede
ocurrir en esto es que tiene que ver con
las tienes el que ataca y tienes que
defiende la El problema es que se puede
dicen que está funcionando uno solo de
los
momentos y que ante los ataques los
operadores tienen tienden a pagar o
bajar
calmar o
estabilizarlos con lo cual descendería
la provisión de energía eléctrica con
eso puede producirse un peligro de que
se afecte el sistema de refrigeración de
los reactores y ahí tendríamos una
situación también parecida a los en el
año este 2011 o sea
recalentamiento de los esto También
estaría
alternamente el Este es el peligro
Y cómo estaba impactando en la guerra el
hecho de que las tropas ucranianas y las
rusas estén tan cerca al ubicarse en
Nico poli en la planta de saporilla
respectivamente
bueno es justamente lo que es una
palabra que usó también este
el señor
las plantas funciona bajo una normalidad
anormal la planta está funcionando en un
contexto absolutamente anormal que es
una guerra o sea se disparan este
artillería vuelan drones de un lado
hacia otro Ese es el el peligro que
tiene esta planta que está en el medio
que este tiga abasteciendo desde la
medida de lo posible energía a la región
entonces puede ser que por parte de los
rusos quieren también la disminución de
la entrega de energía así Eso poder
mejorar su situación táctica o
estratégica y por otro lado de los
ucranianos es este que acusan a los
rusos y en esto también se ha unido al
presidente de Joe biden de calificar a
los
como los rusos tratan la planta Porque
la idea ellos disparan desde la han
instalado también
y listo
de artillería en los alrededores con lo
cual pone en peligro entonces dices una
nueva un nuevo modo ya va a ir en escudo
humano estos son los riesgos